hello freak [ __ ] using CGI and smooth
a lot of it
yeah while what's up like boring but
creative is three years to make this
movie I'm used to making movies that
take curry dance to write three three
years three years Wow
three months to write from beginning to
end some of my snatch was three months
six weeks to shoot two months to edit so
now to us three months to do the whole
thing or to write it but to write it and
to shoot it the whole thing from the
beginning to them we're getting to the
end of six months oh wow and then three
months safer editing so you're wrapped
and packed in nine months ten months so
this is a totally different kind of
commitment yeah as your mind and yeah if
I really knew what I was getting into I
would have asked a double bubble on the
salary because you saw think it could be
a year and a half it's not it's three
years like when you play on a movie like
as a big epic movie do you have an
actual schedule of when you think it's
going to begin when it's going to end or
do you do but you know we the terrain
filmmaking has changed exponentially
like everything a lot with technology so
what was pertinent last year is not
pertinent this year so release dates are
a real dog so we had a release date
which was projected a couple of years
from when you start the movie so they go
right here's a check made a movie you're
coming out in it was we were supposed to
about exactly a year ago but then what
happens is if you're not a branded movie
you get elbowed off that date in Star
Wars or something will come along and
then you're not going to compete with
Star Wars so you've got to move because
you can't compete so you've got a very
crowded market with lots of brands now
this isn't something that we used to
have suffer because everyone was equal
going into the equation you give
yourself the advantage of having a movie
star or something but that doesn't exist
anymore
like this now is the brand is the big
brother so he comes muscling in bullies
his way into a weekend and that's why
you can't really get new films breaking
through
because those occupy those weekends
already occupied so trying to break
through is a real real struggle we had
to wait your year for a date the date
that we're coming out on is one weekend
after guardians now Guardians would be a
fast hit and it's very dangerous being
within the parameters of a big movie
that's a really interesting thing that
only movies have to go through these
days right I mean it's one of the rare
things where people are getting out and
going to see something that's been made
together in a group you know that you're
you're watching media like it's not a
live performance it's something that's
been created and it's going to press
play at 8:00 p.m. on Friday night and
everybody's going to go to see and you
got to get as many of those people
together as you can it's one of the rare
things like that yeah and it's becoming
more polarized so it means more now so
you're opening weekend everything is
about they know what you got to make by
Thursday evening right right you're
coming you're supposed to be coming out
on Friday and everyone knows what you
got to make by Sunday night or Thursday
evening there's enough clever people out
there tapping into clever little boxes
and computer says that they're dead dead
there and they're seldom wrong now that
never used to be the case used to come
out and Phil's would get discovered you
said the platform you start small go big
that's all nonsense now you just got
come out ball swinging and if you don't
come out ball swing and people get very
upset and they think that this is a
failure it hasn't lived up to
expectations even if it's a creative
success yeah but he likes it it's well
again and is a bit of bad you know it is
there is an acceptance say for movies
good movies good and movies find their
own way usually in the end anyway but
the financial aspect has become
polarized it's too significant of a
component and the equations because it
should you know it's an art form right
and the end of the day it's
entertainment and an art form and
somehow you want to unify reconcile that
so because they're essentially different
reckon solos put it in a nice little
package so you put in a pill with a
sweet wrapper around it and then you've
got both
and then you should be happy you should
have the substance and you should have
the flavor but then now the focus is all
on the flavor and not on the substance
and that's result orientated so your
movie comes out they go put it mate
right slow down son what's the movie
line the question first of all should be
what's the movie like rather than what
does it mean and it's just it's become
too competitive into comparative
financially and I love a dollar bill and
I like things are successful but it has
to be secondary towards primary and
primary is what's it like creatively
well a film like nut not to [ __ ] on it
but fast and furious all I heard about
was how much money you made that's all
you hear it's like the big story the big
spaz the Furious opening box-office
hundreds of millions of dollars all you
see is like it's going to make a billion
dollars why do you give a [ __ ] why does
anybody who's watching that give a [ __ ]
you're not getting get any of that money
why is it so appealing that this movie
is made a billion dollars because it's
comparative and it's competitive
yeah and it's lied to people in the
audience because its voice voyeuristic
yeah so you can it's like spectator
sport who's the winner right you don't
do really care about how they won you
just care about the fact that they did
win or like a Floyd Mayweather you want
to find out how much money you made he
made 200 million dollars out of 5 people
get excited about it's an extra element
yeah there is a sort of precarious life
that people can have through sports
stars and liberties and success if they
feel somehow related to or they went on
the opening weekend or they are invested
in then if it's successful then somehow
proliferate armed successful yeah that
gets weird right don't get weird yeah
it's the business of movies is a very
very strange business because your your
creative business but you're also a
business enterprise I mean you're you're
a financial business and when it been
with a guy like you like your movies
have a certain flavor you know you start
off with Lock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels like that movie has a flavor to
it and then your other films like people
want to go to see that kind of flavor
from your films you feel like
pressure in that regard like to live up
to those expectations or to conform to
these ideas that people have of your
movies yes no yes or no
okay it depends what mood you catch me
in right um I like what I do and I'm
going to do it anyway I just like it
very much when people pay me to do it
and give me the money to go and do it so
I don't mind the financial aspect of it
I don't mind films having to compete on
what I'm after is a reconciliation and
as I say that the primary component
should be on the quality of the work
that should be was primary but I don't
grudge films being successful and like
them to be successful I like the
competitive element but sometimes when
you're talking with executives you
realize may your priorities are on the
wrong thing here in the end it is a
creative medium and that is what has to
be primary do they get in the way of a
guy like you though but I would imagine
a guy like you they give you a certain
amount of leeway they give you all the
leeway oh that's beautiful yeah and my
experience with studios will be very
positive and they try to encourage your
hopefully what is your individual
idiosyncrasies they want you to put your
imprint upon the work and they've all
been nothing but encouraging in that
sense but you know people betray their
agendas whilst you know you're in like
conversation or they betray their
priorities so you want to trust a man
because he's a man of substance and to
degree independence so he's not looking
to me to find himself through me so
you're not asking me to tell me you who
you are and that's the ongoing battle of
life right all asking other people to
tell us who we are
right and independence from that is a
man that could be trusted I don't want
anything from you and thereby I can be
kind to you because I don't need to
manipulate you you're no longer a crutch
[Applause]
[Music]